whoops
there it is
hello welcome everybody dogman srianth
pharma jacob wheaton
tattoo
[ __ ]
hey what's up ben
ben what's going on ben pulliam how's it
going
how's it going everyone we ready for
party thor i'm really excited for this
episode
i gotta pull you guys up right here
yeah i am super excited for this episode
i uh
i think this might be one of the better
ones
maybe
we'll see
we'll see i think uh i think this one
i'm i'm really excited for really
excited for
how is everybody
jd here we go again
hello
hi
what's your mouth about
that is my cat rocket named after rocket
raccoo raccoon
his vision gonna drop midnight his
vision's gonna drop midnight also um
you know i'm not sure about that one
because they are releasing all episodes
of star wars visions at once
um
so that's kind of different
um
so i don't know
uh that one i really don't know about
we shall see
let's do this
thor is my
not favorite marvel character because
wolverine's my favorite marvel character
thor is my favorite mcu character
so
i'm really excited to see him
uh that one i really don't know about
sounds like audio is alright huh okay
gonna turn this down
uh yes dylan i am looking
very much forward to venomous derby
carnage i got invited to the premiere
today actually
um
so
that's really cool chris and i both good
to go
um
i'm really excited about that uh what is
star wars visions about um it's
essentially
uh nine episodes they're all different
they don't connect at all they're all
completely different stories and they're
all completely different animations
um they are done by different each each
episode is done by a different animation
studio so
um
there's you know one that's like super
like japanese anime there's another one
that's like an old disney cartoon style
um and overall
i
i think i liked
there's some episodes i truly loved and
i'm like wow i really love that there's
like a good five episodes that i really
love there's one episode
that i hated
i hated it uh
i i really i really did i did not like
it at all
um
i was just
counting the minutes until it was over
but uh
yeah um
most of them
i i very much did enjoy most of them
so
hello hello when does this start well
i'm gonna assume it starts in like 20
minutes they're usually pretty early
how early they usually are
that we don't know
so let's
try to bring up disney plus because it's
not coming up oh there we go
hello hello
uh yep i've seen all the leaked photos
guys
for uh for those asking yep i uh i have
seen
the leaked photo i don't see a leak what
if on here
guys please don't spam in the chat
uh we're gonna have to we'll have to
time you out if uh
if we uh if we see you spammed in the
chat oh no iron fist fan you called me
an mcu fanboy oh
my feelings
of course i'm an mcu fanboy i love it
when people call me that it's not an
insult to me
like in the slightest i obviously am an
mcu fanboy like
um
uh it's it's hard to tell if they're
real or fake
um
because that does seem like a scene that
we would see right um
but uh
it's so hard to tell now because i feel
like with re like the real photos have
come out
and they've been like copyright claimed
but then now i also feel like like the
guy who tried to deep fake everybody and
like secretly he was trolling people
like i feel like people can just make
things now
but since there's like a lot of
watermarks and stuff on them like it
looks pretty real to me you know what i
mean it uh it looks pretty
looks pretty real when a second trailer
knowing home release
uh
i think danielle rpk today said in
november i can do an update video on
that
uh jose andrade i am ready for party
thor i think this is going to be one of
the one of the better episodes i'm
excited about that my camera is uh
there we go
uh 3c films i like chris a lot we talk
uh
we talk and text
uh i think he's a great channel
um i think he's gonna go super super far
probably past me one day i think a lot
of people are probably gonna pass me one
day but you know what
i have a lot of friends in the youtube
community
the real rejects are really good friends
of mine uh in real life uh chris from 3c
is a great guy uh paul from heavy
spoilers is a great guy eric voss is the
man um i love
i love those guys like they're great
guys uh
uh
woof woof from the netherlands too hot
to this mid too
oh it's been such a long
time since i
spoke dutch that was probably
too
expected
food hey everybody shades always coming
in i'm good i'm good good you didn't
miss anything we're just talking about
stuff talking about some spider-man
leaks and stuff like that
yep baby yoda right here someone was
like oh guys i don't have my uh
my logo there we go although it's like
kind of just in the background
why do i say woof woof
i've answered this so many times i need
like to link oh you know what
since i'm posting more on my website now
i need to link
an article that says why do i always say
woof woof and i need to link it in the
pinned comments and say this is why
i say woof um because i've i've added i
i get i obviously understand that new
subscribers come in and don't know why
so i don't mind answering that i just
get asked it a lot
um
it was like my
seventh to
twelfth video
that
i've ever like that like that i ever
posted to youtube um
and here let me i gotta get over here
because i have to
open up my chat so i can
time people out
thank you ryan arfin appreciate that so
uh yeah um so i say woof woof because
like in like my seventh video to my like
twelfth video i don't know
which video it was um
i could probably look and tell you but
we won't do that um
um
it was the black panther
post credits scene um so if you remember
it uh
it was
bucky in wakanda he didn't have the arm
on
um
and the little kids were calling him
white wolf white wolf
now i say white wolf because
like i emphasize wolf because at the
time like it's really funny like when i
started my youtube channel
i i did not expect it to become this i
was just a fan who
liked i loved
the mcu and everything else like all the
superhero stuff like i've loved it since
i was a kid reading comics watching the
the animated shows on tv
you know i grew up on x-men and
spider-man uh the animated shows um so i
just started making videos i never
thought i was gonna be like this
so my enunciation was not very good and
i spoke like really really fast and um i
usually tried to do everything in like
one take so um
i like i was talking about the white
wolf but i said woof like over and over
again like i don't think i said wolf one
time in the
entirety of the video
so all the comments were woof woof like
that's what people were commenting woof
woof like you keep saying woof like you
keep saying wolf you keep saying woof
and uh
so but like no like they were like like
i was being made fun of but like not
really because like at that time i had
like
300 subscribers right so like i you know
the people who commented work were few
at the time so it was like really
funny
it was it was really funny um
and i enjoyed it and so like
since everybody was posting like woof
woof
i just said it
as a joke
and all the comments were like oh my
gosh that's hilarious like
that's so funny that you did that don't
stop don't stop doing that
and i haven't stopped doing it and i
don't know if i still have
these
these original subscribers that i had
three years ago when i started um
i would hope i have some
i would hope i have at least one um
but that's kind of why i say it i say it
because i say it for those old
subscribers before i had like 30
subscribers or something like that um or
30 000 subscribers i say it for those
that are out there and i obviously say
it for my new subscribers as well i
welcome you all to the the wolf family
we we use we used to
i used to call
my subscribers like the wolf pack
or woof gang and maybe maybe we're gonna
have to bring that back
um well i collab with
new rock stars in canadian lad i've
actually collabed with both of them
before
i've actually been on uh rogue theory
with eric voss and the canadian lad and
i did a two-part uh breakdown together
he did like one part on his channel i
did a part of mine and it was really
good and
i like both those guys a lot
um
i see i see you t nasty nelson that you
can't send a super chat um i don't know
why
um
no idea i don't know if harry osborne's
gonna be
part of the sinister six but guys just
so you know if you spam mr anderson is
going to
he's gonna he's gonna time you out and
if you do it'll block you so be careful
he's out there what's up kendrick what's
going on man what announced some few
shows you think they'll announce
november 12th ah geez
um
well i think we're we might get like
we're definitely gonna get some inside
looks
on
of
uh hawkeye miss marvel well wait well
how can i be out already hawkeye might
be out already
um
miss marvel she-hulk i think we're
getting footage for those um keep in
mind it's uh
it's a lot right because you have like
star wars you have all the lucasfilms
like you have a lot um
so because we're gonna get we're gonna
get a lot about uh
kenobi uh ahsoka like there's gonna be a
lot that we're gonna get mandalorian
season three boba fett um
there's a lot that we're gonna get so
keep in mind
it probably won't focus too much on like
one thing for like very very long um
so
yeah
i
as far as like
what shows that i think are gonna come
out that they haven't announced yet
um
that's a tough one
because
i want to say i i want like
a thunderbolts announcement but do i
think it's gonna like happen
no
i don't think i think we're gonna
probably get more about like
iron wars
and like moon night like shows that are
kind of far away that are kind of done
filming
um but not necessarily
like we haven't really gotten anything
for yet um
so
i wanna say
i mean what i would really love to see
is fantastic for i would love to hear
something about the fantastic four
or or the x-men um because we've had a
little bit about the fantastic four
because kevin feige at the disney
investor day
you know he he said like it's in
development like
the project is being worked on right now
but that's it we don't know anything
else about it um
that's all we know about it so uh i'm
hoping we get some information on it
because i
i i really wanna know
about the cast like i really wanna know
about the cast i wanna know who's gonna
play mr fantastic the invisible woman
like
that's what i'm really like i think is
gonna be pretty pretty sweet
so
uh yeah moon knight's gonna be 23 i
think 2023
um
hey dean as nelson i think you you
figured it out i i saw some comments so
you
said you couldn't do it i ever noticed
marvel disney star wars always send a
featured franchise with shows merch
games other various things
it's not letting you use the 499 super
chat well hey i appreciate you using the
9.99 one um
there's like a 99 cents one you can use
too you don't got to spend all that
money but i super appreciate that
um
i have noticed yes i have noticed and um
it's smart right wouldn't you say it's
smart like i
i think it's smart
because and like
one of the things i've actually always
thought was like super smart is that oh
sorry let me fix this don't pop up the
pop-up
uh shopham pandey thank you very much uh
but to get back to you genes nelson um
one thing i always thought was very
smart is since i've been doing youtube
i've done
dc like when i started i did a lot of
videos i i did a lot of dc videos when i
started um
i did just other movies
as well and you know it just became so
dang hard
to keep doing
videos when my my
trailer reactions and my my trailer
breakdowns and even just videos in which
i use like brief clips would get tagged
all the time
because like warner brothers they they
tag stuff all the time sony
uh before i kind of got on a little bit
of their good side uh they used to tag
me all the time like all the time and
and not so much anymore
but uh i think it's genius how disney
and marvel let like youtubers
use their stuff because it's free
promotion right because trust me like
yeah these people are like the companies
are making money off youtube but let
come on let's be honest that's not where
they're really making their money from
they make money from merchandise they
make money from the movies from disney
plus right you know what i mean like
yeah it's a revenue stream for them but
to them they're more worried about
getting their shows out there because
they know that ultimately that will
bring them more money than youtube views
right
whereas my whole life depends on youtube
views but uh
yeah dean s nelson
i think it's very smart of them to do
that
and i actually do think they
intentionally leak some like merch and
stuff sometimes infinity shades back
again love to see wanda and peter parker
have some nice wholesome scenes
personally i wish they did more of the
avengers mingling and becoming closer
like we saw a vicious party after an
avengers age of ultron
i think it would be really cool to see
peter and wanda um because i think
they're so different
um i'm really excited to see wanda's
future
especially in multiverse of madness
because like
she's very wounded and like
raw right now and
uh
i think her story is going to be pretty
big and and doctor strange um
i think it's going to be pretty big and
yeah i i'm wondering if peter is going
to have like a big leadership role in
the new avengers and i'm excited to see
him see him like interact with like
falcon again because i think the last
time i really saw them together with the
exception of like the big fight in
avengers end game was um
during the the airport scene in civil
war
and which was pretty funny and comical
and which you know the the big joke is
is you know tom hall and kick sebastian
stands but you know peter parker kicked
sam wilson's but so i'd like to see them
interact
um i'd like to see him interact with
shanghi i'd like to see them to fight
together i think that would be pretty
cool um yeah i know i i agree i think
there should be some like good scenes
between the avengers
like hanging out right i'd like to see
them together when they're not you know
being avengers like i think that would
be cool
i think we may see the maestro soon
you know
i'm with you there
and oh
it's out
but i i hear eugene nelson
i probably agree with you
it kind of seems like that and i wonder
you know you wonder what ruffalo is
going to do right but um
all right we are starting fam it is out
we are going to be starting
five
four
three
two
one
and then we're just gonna i know it's
just gonna go through the
whoa this episode's 35 minutes long
we are being spoiled today
and i
am not going to skip past the the
the trailer part here
or the the trailer the intro
time to pop open a g fuel thank you to g
fuel because they are part of the reason
i'm going to the venom premiere getting
me close with sony
if you drink g-full you can use code
cosmic
cosmicgfield.com
to get a discount
all right
all right same intro as normal time
space
reality
we're still just going through the intro
right now guys
vast new realities
what if
what if
all right how are we starting off here
jane foster
i can hear cat dennings
i can hear
it's doing the beeping
she know who shield it she knows whose
shield is
well
the invasion has begun well this is very
different
oh that's vegas it's not germany like i
thought it was
your dull lives are about to come to an
end
the
the party prince what
oh outdoor looking
they're trying to talk for many lessons
you returned him
the odin sleep
yep
and now thor's like okay let's party
what
no parties of course mother hey i'm dole
i'm duel will be watching but is
heimdall a partier is the question
[Laughter]
the most interesting thing he's done is
fall asleep
you're called frica
alert the realms
party on midgard
to thor the party prince really
hey look who it is
it's magic
huzzah
interesting
it sounds like cat denis and natalie
portman
oh look oh the hair
he's beautiful
hey howard comes back
howard the duck
the scroll
you do me
not
all the way down there
hey
hi grand master
oh thanks marie
womb
i think i
pronounced that right
bring the thunder
don't drink too much or a little
that was an excellent party
[Laughter]
you killed a planet
oh
thor is such a smooth talker
dang
this is the
hey
swinging the hammer it is the
grandmaster
nice
release the [ __ ]
hey look who it is they're gambling
mama needs a brand new eye that's
hilarious
hey drags valkyrie
no way
that's epic
hey
that's cool
wait is this all really happening
i really hope this is all really oh
looks like uh
it looks like some people had some fun
looks like a lot of people have some fun
well look at those baby little thingies
they on asgard
oh no they're in a hotel
it kind of sounds like natalie but i
would like i didn't check either
oh look who it is
[ __ ] rockets
passed out
maria hill
acting director
the hell's nick fury
oh
still unconscious
there's a rabbit in this thing he's
talking about rocket
hey a helicarrier
she slept with thor
the party atmosphere seems to be
spreading
i don't
doesn't sound like natalie portman
it is cat denny's though
the last resort has arrived
oh
captain marvel
sending
it's done
hey
look at this
oh it's
loki
whoa that's very different oh that's
very different
i
only poop in private oh
loki it's a shooting sir
oh no it's baseball
the ice bros loki himself prince loki
this is freaking epic
we're having a great time
she smacked at him
dang
oh
she uppercut the heck out of him
oh
but thor has a hammer
oh that's such a cool scene
hammering
you want me to put the hammer down say
it
say it
he smacked the hell he smacked her into
space
he smacked her into the
inspector to the uk
at least oh no
[Music]
i don't know what these are no one
nobody does
i have to do a little boop
you weird rocks
oh
can she lift the hammer
so they're in america now
arizona somewhere maybe
party file
be right with you one second
let's do this
oh
[Laughter]
oh the lightning is it just gonna
supercharger it's super charging her
that's a tony stark move right there
oof
captain marvel can absorb energy dude
so i wanna can she pick up the hammer
that's my question
all right
what you meant about we're watching t
we're watching the show
come on thor
oh
that's pretty cool
that's freaking cool
oh
they both
oh you put the hammer on her now he
can't move no she can't move
the time out
is that look that's like a celestial guy
on the left
not an actual celestial but someone
dresses celestial
that's funny
that your cat could devour whole armies
please
thor called jane
um
she said love you
they said a swear word
hello
oh it's howard the dirk
this is the duck
oh look it's okay
late night chinese
oh thor's phone broke
dang
now she broke her phone
how would you call his mom
laughs
he just took out a whole power grid
get it cuz he's from australia
oh
[Laughter]
oh she's like all powered up
oh she called heimdall
oh she got taken
and now they're in one of the dakotas
south dakota i think
oh look he's summoned her
i actually felt that one
mrs odin's wife
crushing my mellow
wonder what's about to happen here
oh
oh no
what are you
i'm in my room studying
polar bear in the back
you come in here
we never get the fire the nukes
it's a sphere there's no corners that's
a sphere
the universe's greatest slingshot
oh
see you in another thousand years dang
my mother is coming
oh
i'm your brother from another
you sound like odin
you don't have to go home but you can't
stay
most of the guardians
we're keeping the scoot scoots
i hear my dad calling that's thanos
oh father give me strength
to do what
oh
my mother is coming frigga
everyone freaking
he fixed the stone edge
they're fixing everything well power
grids back up okay
oh sure is gone
kind of fixed the statue of liberty
there we go oh even the frost giants
came back and helped
he
he put the leaning power leaning tower
pisa back upright
[Laughter]
dude that's so good
learning is magic
the snuggie
i wonder who that is
hey
i know who you are
the hammer really the hammer was
wow
he came back to see jane
oh
huh
i know a whole planet full of unicorns
that's funny
i like that they get together even in
the animated series i like
i like that loki and thor are still kind
of brothers
wait what oh here we oh snap
ultra
ultron
[Music]
with vision in its side oh no and this
is what here we go even the freaking
watcher was uh
wow even the watcher was
even the watcher was alright is there a
post credit
no post credit
i thought there might have been
let's look at the cast i want to see all
the voices
i think i passed all the way
go back
based on the marvel comics of course
yeah yep
show me okay cast
it was natalie portman tom hiddleston
kat dinnings samuel jackson jeff
goldblum kobe smulders clark greg frank
gorilla tiger with tt karen gillan jamie
alexander seth green is hard to doug
alexandria daniels
and then
yeah wow they got a lot of uh wow they
got a lot of people to come do the uh
the voices oh i like this episode i
thought it was fun
i thought it was funny this was a good
one let's get chris up in here i really
like this episode
that might be tied for my favorite
strange supreme one is uh my favorite i
think
hi
oh hold on he can't he can't hear me
that was awesome
it was a fun time oh hold on people
can't hear you
hear me
oh hey guys
i only have one issue with the whole
thing nope shut up
nope i have i have to ruin so i'll be
the party pooper
everybody call crystal party pooper in
the chat
everybody call chris party pooper in the
chat everybody do it and here's why
here's why why well you can't call me a
party pooper now let me be a party
pooper
do you not think he wouldn't be worthy
to have the hammer
yeah it'd be worthy
what do you mean he's lost it for less
has he though
i think so
why did he lose it in the first story i
i think he's i think he was just kind of
on a vacation
i don't know yeah i think it was just
kind of a vacation do you really take
someone's worthiness away for wanting to
have a little bit of fun i think
worthiness is about the heart
and his heart wasn't in the place of
somebody who's going to protect the nine
realms i would argue he wasn't worthy
but what say you oh wise chat
uh and [ __ ] finity shades thanks so much
for that super chat and yeah it was a
great episode i know oh it was fantastic
yeah i think i i i think i'd give it a
10 out of 10 because i i think it was it
was what i've been wanting from the
series because i know it's not that
serious
so make it fun
yeah
make it fun to watch you know what i
mean like and that was just i i
literally and i'll have to go back and
watch it
i laughed so hard at some point i don't
remember
uh yeah oh infinity shades brings up a
good point there would be no worthy
enchanting on the hammer uh
because why not well because odin didn't
send the hammer to earth and he get put
the enchantment on it before he sends it
to earth remember he says he would
whoever be worthy whoever finds his
hammer if he be worthy will will the
power of thor he's the one who puts the
enchantment on it before he sends it to
earth because he's he he banishes door
to earth
and then he has his hammer then he puts
the enchantment on it and then he throws
it down with him that's a fair argument
i'll give him that i'll give that oh
that's that's something in the mcu right
that's the mc you know i solved that i
solved that yeah you solved it he solved
it
that's not the word i can't think of the
word i'm trying to say but i agree that
makes sense
now it's not a 9.9 now it's a 10.
there you go
i uh that was it was really cool
fighting too
uh oh no the fight at one point yeah
when he was checking the lightning at
her and then just kept checking more i
said i said
next time on dragon balls
this kind of looks like dragon ball z i
was like next time on dragon ball z on
the next episode of dragon ball z
no this was it was a lot of fun the
jokes the references the characters kat
dennings is just hilarious everywhere
she shows up
this is our first oh what was what was
the term they used
uh
international relations oh is that what
the kids are calling it nowadays
[Laughter]
so much fun so much fun and then of
course
the big huge ending
that was so good
i
i think it was good how they did loki
um
i liked the loki thing how they were
still brothers right
uh that was still really cool i don't
know i just and they had a bunch of
characters there show up for the you
know party what what i do have i do have
a counterpoint
snapped away on my side of the chat says
there was some type of spell on the
hammer because captain marvel could not
get it off of her
true
that is a good counterpoint
a lively debate tonight boys that's why
we're here though a lot of fun
regardless of that
really and because in reality it doesn't
matter it's very possible that he really
just was worthy because he's thor and he
doesn't have to be
perfect well it's also uru metal and
remember he did say
he did say about stormbreaker about uru
metal before he made stormbreaker
you know he that he was telling
the guardians like your mind would
collapse and you know you could not
wield it you don't have the power to
wheel it so maybe it's just the uber
metal it's maybe extremely heavy right
it's just extremely powerful and he's a
god so he has the ability to lift it
that's true as well that's true as well
lively debate though good job chat for
uh bringing in some really good points
all of you guys
hey infinity shades thanks for that
super chat i'm really glad you like
shang chi it's uh
one of my favorite movies now and
yeah he's freaking awesome
brandon pifer can we call him voltron
voltron
and chen you bring up a good point bowie
what you say she said i'm not a fan of
how these episodes feel like half
episodes due to the cliffhanger endings
however
this one we're going to get resolution
right am i right in that one
we'll say it again
we're going to get resolution from this
cliffhanger there's more story coming oh
yeah this is this is now the part this
is the big two finale this is the two
finale now where ultron is taking over
this is what i've been saying from the
beginning old john's taking over the
multiverse even the watcher was like
wait the watch was surprised too he's
like what's going on yeah so now the
watcher
this whole time and nobody told me
because i talk so quietly
yeah that's what it is
because you talk so quietly um i
actually have no clue why
uh you do your thing i'll figure that
out we need warren
hey there's a apparently a leaked photo
of professor xavier i saw that
it didn't it wasn't a very convincing
photo it's not a convincing photo it's a
drawing
but apparently it's getting taken down
apparently people are like this is all
right
thank you for letting me know
it looks
we're talking about the professor x
photo that went out and doctor strange
madness i mean
my problem my only issue with these is
it's always the same like what's the
actual connection what connects this to
multi doctor strange and the multiverse
of madness what connects what this show
this photo
this photo what's the connection here i
don't there's no like oh yeah this is
taken from the set
but i don't know i mean that'd be cool
if it was true and i wouldn't be
surprised if it were
i think he's in it i mean he
remember you said he met with kevin
feige oh yeah no 100 and i don't think
he's gonna say yep we talked about it
i'm in
right
i'm kind of looking right now
yeah i mean
interesting
an interesting part definitely look into
a little bit because
anything it will be an interesting video
yeah no kidding
well but uh
the same with those leaks that
disappeared off the internet for
spider-man no way home that supposedly
revealed the sinister six but they're
just gone it's like what they're gone
they gotta be somewhere
they gotta somebody's gotta have them
feige has him in his vault with the
fights
next to all of his weapons i mean he's
his infinity gun next to his freaking
sniper rifles that he's got with a
picture of my freaking face on it like
with you know he's got like x's marked
from other freaking youtubers and i'm
still i don't have an x through my name
yet it's like harry potter how like
they're thinking off how many more how
many more strikes do you have though
that's true
i've got little i've got little ticks by
my name and
he's just waiting to like
strike three pull the trigger on cosmic
we got him
yeah
hold on super chat from isaiah
richardson jr thank you hammer was
always enchanted thor
and thor and grew up seeing it become
and it became prince when he lifted it
in the mcu odin stripped aways
away thor's power away and did a second
enchantment send it to earth
yeah i mean there probably was some type
of enchantment on it
um i still don't think he passed the
threshold of being unworthy that's all
i just think it was questionable
uh yeah i don't think he became unworthy
that's what i'm saying but i was
bringing up the point that potentially
he could have been if odin really cared
you know i guess he was in a deep sleep
so he isn't even there to challenge oh
that's when i laughed really like
the most exciting thing my father ever
did was fall asleep i laughed
so hard at that part
i think stopping by i laughed probably
harder than i should have laughed at
them
it was like what so okay yeah
so ultron is totally
uh infiltrating
the baltimores and it's uh
the big question is does this bleed into
the live-action mcu
we'll see
i mean so here's one thing that's
happening and i we were actually talking
about this over on my side and i'm sure
you've thought about it we know for a
fact we're getting disney plus day
december 12th yeah
you know which maybe we'll get a trailer
for this that the other couple release
dates but you have to at least hope that
we'll be getting some new projects
revealed
yeah but they're not gonna be movies
because it's disney plus day they're
gonna be disney plus projects so the
question is you know what merits of
disney plus show what's gonna be
announced because it's not gonna be you
know the fantastic four they're gonna
get a movie i don't know but maybe
new stuff we're gonna get though
well they announced new titles pretty
far into the future and maybe we won't
maybe we will but regardless eventually
we're going to get new stuff yeah maybe
we get white vision versus
vision ultron and that's a series you
know i have no clue but they can do
whatever they want with this disney plus
shows it opens up such a huge door of
possibility and opportunity they can do
whatever they want because of the
multiverse now like they can literally
do whatever they want so yeah i mean we
could definitely see all this bleed into
what's really happening
but
and maybe they're bringing ultron back
period and and
you know that'd be fun white vision is
ultron secretly yeah maybe the young
avengers take out ultron maybe
um hold on
kamke thanks for the super chat like the
episode get it to cartoon but why the
military didn't show up once it took
freaking like eight years to travel to
the park
yeah i mean
maybe it's just because
they left it up to shield
right because that's what shield does
they're the ones who who deal with that
stuff i mean i guess if you think about
it
shield is the only people who showed up
and like the regular thor too right like
the military didn't show up to inspect
everything in that small town it was
thor or it was shield that killed right
so
i mean sticking with the same
kind of basis there yeah you want to
know what i was curious to i was like
why are you acting director what
happened to fury you want to know why
i'm acting directly
oh is he okay he's still unconscious
i kind of like maria hill giving captain
marvel all that crap
yeah
it's about time somebody put her in her
place i just can't i don't i don't like
captain america yeah i know i was saying
that the whole time
it's like she's just
she really is just a party pooper
it's not even like brie larson it's just
no it's just the way the attitude of the
character yeah i don't i think they i
don't think they did a good job i think
they want to i think they could have
went in a different direction to really
make the character like great like and i
think they possibly got that feedback
from the fans i feel like the majority
of us feel that way i won't speak for
everybody but i think probably the
majority people would say yeah it's just
kind of off-putting so hopefully that
will change in the future brie larson's
a fantastic actress you know and uh
she's just doing what she was directed
oh i i i
was very abrasive yeah i was always a
big brie larson fan i think
she's doing some weird stuff now but
that's her life dude you know do what
yeah do you um
i i but i've always really liked brie
larson i just no i didn't like the
betrayal of captain marvel yeah she's
very abrasive
party pooper
yeah and again i don't think it's brie
larson's fault but i do think they are
poking fun of that in this episode i
think a little bit i think marvel's
heard the fans party people
and everything like that
um thank you snapped away thank you for
stopping by yeah they're kind of they're
kind of playing into that
and who knows maybe the marvels will be
a lot better maybe it'll be funnier um
i'm i'm certainly like
hoping that she gets uh redemption
there shouldn't be any issue with that
and you know we've seen in chiang chi
she's not going anywhere she's she's at
the end of that she's
important and she's going to be
important in the cosmic connection to
earth she actually
and she's separating she did seem a
little bit better there didn't she
at that point yeah 100 she wasn't
talking down to everybody she was just
like no no no
yeah we'll have to see though that's a
that's an important part moving forward
and it is cool as you're reading the
freaking all the chris hemsworth natalie
portman kat dennings
literally all of them in this in this
episode
it was a purebred episode for actors
and um you get another connection to
these characters even though they're not
necessarily the same connection
they're different multiverse characters
but it is fun to see them in that
different light yeah it's cool it's cool
and i think uh
i don't know i do think there are a lot
of people that really like captain
marvel the way she is which good for you
like that's that's nice i just it it's
off-putting to me
um
i feel like she's way too serious but
maybe that's just her whole shtick
yeah but everybody can just goof about
all the time
i'm definitely more of like a thought a
thor
type of character absolutely that was
fun that was that was a boss dj wavy d
do you think they're gonna rush kang and
galactus i feel like there's so many
threats out there kangalak just won the
spider-verse smaller ones thank you for
that super chat uh no i don't think
marvel ever really rushes anything i
think they take their time
uh i think everything's well thought out
um
i i don't think they're going to rush
all that i think it it's going to hit
perfectly uh
i agree 100 with that yeah
so
searcher flirting with the statue of
liberty was funny as hell yes nothing it
was i have somebody asking at the end
who was the guy at the end that was
ultron
but
vision vision fusion
it's like
it's a
voltron
it's almost like ultron survived right
if you think in the terms of the main
mcu timeline granted it's a different
universe i presume ultron survived
he would have built vision's body for
his own consciousness
well
but that's what was happening age of
ultron he was building
he was building visions body to
so i mean essentially this is could have
this could be what happened like
because ultron was in the vibranium body
or maybe it wasn't my brain at first
ultron was in the body and then he was
building vision
yeah he was gonna take over that right
so it seems like he probably did that
no it's yeah yeah but it seems like in
he did take over
the actual vision body and then took his
old body and put it on his armor as well
yeah yeah is what it kind of looks like
definitely looks like that and then
collected all the infinity stones
yeah uh
joaquin fernandez
a lot of us hate captain marvel in the
comics too carol was great as miss
marvel but it's captain marvel she's
horrible she has a superiority complex
now characters like wonder woman don't
see that's that's actually my that's
exactly that that's my thing is the
superiority complex like
i don't i don't care that she's like
super serious and everything like that
and i'm not talking about this episode i
think this episode was good and i think
her offset to thor in this episode was
like really good it was perfect yeah
they pulled the perfect character to
fight party thor right yeah i just uh i
think the superiority complex is a thing
that really bugs me yeah and torqued on
my side says yeah to me captain marvel
in her origin movie isn't humble at all
it's not pleasant to watch somebody that
is constantly full of themselves right
that's and that's that's the deal right
and they don't know pleasantry there no
it whereas with thor he's full of
himself but there's a lot of there's a
lot of quirks and it's funny
to offset that
yeah again
you know like captain marvel two comes
out i'm gonna watch captain marvel too
like it's not keeping me oh for sure
yeah i'm not and i think her character
will evolve a little bit kind of has to
who knows
kyram thanks for super chats this
episode felt like something on disney xd
that's pretty good that's pretty funny
talk about how cool loki was dude loki
was happy you're like my brother from
another mother i was like yeah brothers
brothers forever
oh that's not she's not my mother
we're a brother from another mother
remember yeah right
uh who created oh and kyra thank you for
that super chat who created ultron in
this universe
uh
in the mcu or in
in in what i think what we just saw i
mean i don't think i don't think he came
from that universe yeah he definitely
came for another universe
which is why the watcher which is why
the watcher was freaking out
so he's like
he's like
what the you know
what i see everything and all the
universes like
what's happening
right yeah even all the superior beings
saw whatever ultron did and it was you
know a nexus event
this wasn't supposed to happen who in
what is this
and that might be why the watcher fights
him in the final one you know i i think
so yeah
isaiah richardson jr thanks for another
super chat there wouldn't be a vision
without thor joining the avengers to
power him in the first place but this
ultron can be from another universe
yeah i totally i totally think it's he's
got to be from another universe uh and
and again i i think that's why the
watcher is so
like confused
because he's just kind of like
i see everything i didn't see this this
came out of nowhere so clearly i think
he comes from a different universe
um
what's my opinion
on marvel
making hulk week in the movies um
i don't like it
uh i'm waiting for like
world breaker hulk
yep that's
at least one time or something like way
different like maestro hulk um
i don't like
like i like hulk in avengers the first
avengers
and
like i liked him in
ragnarok
but i was not a big fan of professor
hulk
especially the part where he cringes at
his former self when they're in the past
i cringed at that part
like i cringed at him cringing at his
former self because i like his former
self more than
his current self
so i was like
yeah
so will we see king in this what if
season i don't believe so
no i think a lot of thing we need to
discover in the real world before we can
get him and what if i think
i think um ultron is the finale i think
yep i think um
the watcher in the next episode will
gather
different people from different
universes
supreme strange supreme yep
and then i think the last episode will
be the last battle
it's kind of cool that they decided to
connect them at the end and that'll grab
everything right that'll definitely make
the next episodes more
yeah and it's a cool way to bring back
you know the other characters well maybe
they'll get the spider-man from the
zombie movie or
bring in zombie
zombie thanos let's go
oh gosh with the infinity stones oh
maybe ultron killed maybe ultron killed
him or took him from zombie thanos
because there you go
there's an easy place and get all the
infinity stones yeah right oh look a
dead thanos
um
i was gonna address something but i
don't remember
brian slick um
you guys are aware that carol is
essentially goddess military yes i've
worked fighter pilots in iraq danvers is
a right cow compared to real
fighter pilots is a rake hell
i've never heard that expression i've
never heard that expression either i
don't know if you're saying she's better
or worse i'm sorry i really don't
um i'm not questioning whether or not
the character is the way the character
is supposed to be i think the big
question is only
is she fun to watch and i think the
answer is no regardless of if her
personality is warranted called for
appropriate inappropriate i just don't
think people enjoy watching it
regardless i think
exactly what you just said i think the
character
is done properly done the way it's
supposed to be done i think
they had a vision for it and they did it
yeah i just i don't like captain marvel
like i don't like her attitude i i
i i did kind of enjoy captain marvel the
movie it's not a movie i hated
i didn't like how she just came in an
end game and was like oh look at me i'm
stronger than everybody that was stupid
like we spent years building up other
characters um
you know
again just to come and kind of say
captain mark will fix everything you
know it's just kind of like
um
it was really weird to me it didn't make
a lot of sense to me because she would
like fight thanos and like kind of beat
him but then he'd just like throw her
out of nowhere um
and then she was like out for like
minutes at a time i'm like how are you
just like
clearly stronger than thanos and then he
like throws you into some rocks and
you're down and tony has to die and
everything like to me that just it was a
big plot hole to me and i didn't like
that i didn't like them
doing that but uh
yeah for the people saying wrong oh
you're wrong captain america wasn't like
that like that's your own opinion
not wrong it's my opinion i don't like
her and that's just how it is
like and i'm not i'm never gonna
apologize for that i don't like the
character maybe she'll make a redemption
maybe not there's other characters i
don't like the mcu
you know i love wanda i love thor i love
dart strange i love spider-man there's
characters i like characters i don't
like
yeah and that goes out to everybody and
that's completely just 100 if you like
the character that's awesome for you i'm
sure there are people out there that
don't like iron man i don't like captain
america and i get crap for it all the
time i don't like captain america either
i mean i don't mind captain america but
i've never been like a gung-ho captain
america fan yeah and there are people
who love him and he's their favorite
avenger and i get that you got to
remember that everybody identifies to
characters
depending on where they are in their
lives depending on different memories
they have as childs there's so many
different aspects and that's why the mcu
has been built into what it is that
we're literally sitting here on youtube
live talking about it and people here
joining with us because of those
memories and those connections and each
to their own i do however firmly believe
the overwhelming majority
don't prefer to watch captain marvel
and i've never made fun of anybody for
liking anything i've never
i've seen people talk about captain
marvel all the time and i've never been
like that's dumb like
they shouldn't like captain marvel
because i'm a firm believer letting
people like what they like i mean
i do like what says mozo i definitely
pronounce that name wrong but monica
rambo with her little screen time better
than carol danvers
i'm excited to see monica rambo in the
in the future of the mcu she's gonna be
a blast
yeah i mean and i actually do think the
combination of uh miss marvel carol
danvers and monica rambo's that's going
to make for a pretty good movie i think
the three of them together are actually
going to be something pretty exciting
especially if they're linking it to like
secret wars i think it's going to be a
pretty big movie actually
um so
um
there's a question i wanted to address
where was it
uh
infinifan80 personally i really like
carol's personality
it worked well in this episode she was
the straight man to thor's hygiene and
i'm not disagreeing with that i actually
think it did really work well for the
episode i'm strictly talking about the
mcu
okay brian's like thanks for another
super chat appreciate you
explaining rachel recluse as for her
superiority her char has more
responsibility than all the avengers
combined maybe you guys would like
captain america better if her name was
carl danvers no not at all this has
nothing to do with her being a woman
nothing at all and i hate people who's
one of warren's favorite superheroes of
all time is wonder woman guys wonder
woman is one of my favorites of all the
time there's a picture of her hanging on
my wall right there i have zero problem
with female superheroes i love female
superheroes and i probably would rather
watch them than male superheroes
no it has nothing to do with that i
don't like the character there's not
there's nothing deeper than that it's
like it doesn't go any deeper than that
no i don't care
it has nothing to do with the fact that
she's a woman
and i mean i didn't necessarily really
like marvel
and i like jude
and i like jude law
but
i think and i think it's kind of a
bummer because the story not the story
yeah the story
had a lot of potential
and i still think like the cree scroll
war does have a lot of potential
and that'll be fun yeah yeah yeah so
yeah
i think and to finish up here we should
talk about what if for a second
um
the um
the future of this series hopefully
continues on in season two because they
said we're gonna get some phase force
characters in season two and they set
the precedent here that they are
actually all going to connect at the end
which is just going to make it a lot
more enjoyable you know you and i have
talked off camera a little bit about
what is it that what if is potentially
missing compared to other mcu stories
and that is the speculation but where is
this going right right and and they gave
that to us tonight which has me really
excited for the remaining episodes and
for future seasons
yeah
and i think stakes
have
made it a little less exciting
um but but
but when you have episodes like this and
when you have episodes like the strange
supreme one that i really really enjoyed
i don't think you necessarily need all
that stuff
i think good episodes will get people
excited i think
what if has
i think what if has been like an okay
series it's had a lot of great episodes
and some that were a little lackluster
um yeah but you know what and speaking
of the like the theme of this like chat
tonight about opinions and everything
i've seen the episodes that i really
didn't like people are like this was a
10 out of 10. i really like this episode
and i've seen some people say this is
the worst episode so far like and that's
just how it is and that's okay like it
doesn't matter nothing wrong with that
right we actually reunited we act like
it's such a big problem that we disagree
and have different opinions but it's
really not like it's it's okay
yeah how boring these conversations
would be if we agreed on absolutely
everything that too yeah that was
awesome 10 out of 10. yeah 10 out of 10.
cool good night like right it's our
differences that unite us isn't it right
and and i just saw someone say this like
why don't i like captain america uh i
mean i don't dislike him i just
i don't get really excited by him that
much i have an emotional connection yeah
i don't really have a big emotional
connection to him whereas like
iron man i i particularly enjoy thor i
particularly enjoy
um
i don't dislike captain america by any
means
um i like him he's just not my favorite
you know
i just he's
he he stands for a lot of good
and i like that about him and that's
what warren doesn't like about him yeah
right now he stands for like america
needs to be more evil yeah that's what
it is no uh he stands for a lot of good
that's and that is what i really like
him i like his patriotism um
there's a lot that i do like about
captain america and i re-watched captain
america the first movie the other day
and i was like dang i forgot how good
this movie was that's not like i don't
like him and i really enjoy the movies
captain america won a soldier and
captain america civil war two of my
favorite movies
uh
but as far as like who's your favorite
superhero i'm never like captain america
like
i just
would i like to be captain america yes
[Laughter]
yes
i mean i mean if for being honest i'd
just love to be chris chris evans you
know
there you go yeah um but but again like
and and who was it it was uh brian slick
thanks for that super chat i i hope i
didn't offend you in any way that's not
my intentions um
oh would you guess you got another one
hey this ironic uh
live action
fire what if to mcu marvel will be
taking a huge risk of losing the
mainstream audience if the live action
mcu gets
comic style uh i probably agree to that
and you know i i didn't like
maybe i got a little worked up but you
know i wasn't like taking that as like
attack or anything i appreciate the
super chats um it came with super chat
yeah yeah yeah no no i i i super
appreciate the super chats and um
i like when people have different
opinions and i respect the different
opinions um
as far as that risk you're talking about
i have to agree um
i think marvel
has i don't know what to call this i i
think like
i guess research they have like really
good
they do really good research
like uh like to things pertaining to
their audience um
i don't know the word for that like uh
like research and development teams that
they like might have to like kind of get
the audience feedback there's a word for
it i just can't i just can't think of it
um
dang it yeah i can't say the word but i
think uh
disney marvel they do a really good job
at knowing like what their audience
likes and i think they also do a good
job at
planning things out and honestly i have
a lot of faith in kevin feige
honestly
yeah i just have a lot of faith in kevin
feige i mean the dude's been in the
industry for a really long time he's
worked with marvel since like the first
x-men films um and i just think the
guy's a genius and i don't think we've
really been
like let it led astray so far by him and
by the team
um
yeah and like some some people
may not like some movies that come up
but i think the overall like collective
story has been pretty good and i think
i think with like multiverse of madness
and spiderman no way home and like
pretty much like i think all the like
these movies that are coming out are
going to be like really big
which is why we have the disney plush
shows
that are like kind of the smaller
stories but
like if you look at ant-man um he was
never like
his movies were never like super super
big
right
but i think ant-man 3 is going to be
huge with the you know introduction of
kang and multiverse of madness is going
to be bonkers you know so we hear
we already know about spider-man
and
what are the other movies the marvels
you know are going to have a lot of
superheroes in them already as it is
it's going to be a huge movie i mean
there's just like so much huge stuff
coming up
that i just kind of have faith
um
that they that they know their audience
they know what to do and what not to do
but i mean you bring up a really good
point and i i agree with you but
no but
i i just would add
that i'm not so afraid
of that mistake happening because
i trust feige
and maybe we have this conversation in a
year
after we've seen some movies and it's
like oh you know maybe you know maybe i
agree about but you know
i agree with what what he said 100
but i also feel like we are getting to
that point in the generational gap where
marvel might not necessarily need to
rely on those comic fans anymore you
know we're going to get to the point in
the next 10 years where a lot of these
kids haven't even read the comics
and you know marvel is what kevin feige
says marvel is not what it used to be
so there is there is to an extent i
believe um
that separation is happening as we get
into the more digital world and kids
aren't reading comics you know these
people who grow up with tom holland as
their spider-man and
there will be that that difference
eventually that they're going to start
writing comic books off of the movies
not the other way around
i
i
i actually question now
and kevin feige has you know
stated plenty of times that
you know these stories are inspired by
the comics they're they're obviously not
like
shot for sure shot for shot remakes like
not even close right like look at
infinity gauntlet like oh yeah so
different it's the x-men
fantastic four they're like everyone's
there uh you know nebula takes the
gauntlet snaps mephisto's involved it
also it takes place in space right and
like this huge
giant structure that thanos made um it's
so different but you know it's inspired
by that um also the gauntlet doesn't
like
deteriorate whenever you snap
thanos uses thanos is about 150 million
times stronger yeah like dennis uses it
so much but
um i question now
how many of the fans of the mcu actually
read comics though yeah and that's why i
was bringing up that point is because i
do think a good majority of the fans are
you know us those older guys who grew up
reading comics and then watching the
animated show on saturday morning and
then all of a sudden movies started
coming out
but everybody younger than us
who were you know
10 when iron man came out and maybe even
a little younger or older
that's a whole different generation of
fans that that marvel's probably more
focused on than even us i would also arg
i would also say that
not argue i don't know
where is it oh i also think iron man
and this is actually one of the reasons
why i love iron man so much to have an
emotional connection to him i think he
mainstreamed a lot of this not in the
comics since his comics were not very
successful
so
mcu iron man's like streamlined
uh
superhero culture i guess is what i'll
call it and i'm totally not neglecting
everything that happened with like dc
and all the batman's and everything
before and the fantastic fours and the
x-men and everything like that but the
start of the mcu was something special
and and i think i was built on iron man
and iron man built it and i think he
really
whereas like in the past
like
we were nerds
for liking comments like
in like in the way that people would use
it in a derogatory way
and iron man
and of course everyone before him
spider-man x-men the fantastic four uh
all the batman's that came before him
keaton
uh val kilmer george clooney uh you know
christian bill i think they all paved
this way to eventually lead up to iron
man to kind of mainstream
the superheroes and make it like the
good nerd
you know what i mean
no for sure like
yeah
no i'm i'm a big fan of iron man
i think the most important and we see in
the comment section and in twitter and
personal conversations non-stop oh big
fan service big fan service big fan
service and i think that there are
moments put in there for fans for comic
book fans for superhero fans for pop
culture fans but i think kevin feige's
first
priority is marvel
and then the fans he's trying to create
something that can continue on on its
own and for the sake of adding you know
fan services and losing some of that
substance i just don't think kevin feige
has interest in that i do the guy lives
breathes
and just everything he does is marvel
and his first priority is going to be
marvel in the future of art
yeah totally
totally totally
well that was that was a chat tonight
guys we're gonna yeah we got indeed boys
that was fun that was some deep chats
but i don't ever mind going deep like
that i know some people shy away from it
but
um
we only ever have good intentions you
know when we talk about like yeah we may
not like some of the same characters but
that's okay
um
and one day warren and i will get on and
we'll find the thing we most disagree on
and we'll just yell at each other for an
hour
we do it in real life one day we'll do
it in person
so but uh you know
i really like this episode i don't know
it's a good turn for what if i don't
know
there's a beat this is beat strain
supreme episode for me
this is my new number one favorite
strange supremes
three or four this was
lighter
that you could say that yes
so it's kind of an understatement
but i i liked how
i like the emotion
that the shock factor i like the emotion
the shock factor like i don't know what
i really liked him trying to save her
over and over again and i liked the fact
that he couldn't
no there's no questioning that it was a
fantastic episode the question is which
was better
yeah
i'm putting i'm putting this at my
number one it had everything i wanted to
see and what if as much as i enjoyed the
surprise and the shock of
strange supreme i just like to see these
characters in a different light and
there were so many of them in this with
the original voices and it was just a
lot of fun
i'm gonna give this one my number one oh
marina thank you for the 15 super chat i
appreciate it don't go too deep
i i think
i think it i think it does take my
number one favorite episode for what if
because i i don't know when the last
time i laughed as loud as i did
that's true and some of these it gave me
some really good laughs
that i don't think i've gotten in a long
time from like a show that's not
specifically a comedy you know what i
mean
yeah for sure
yeah no i i would say this takes my
number one
but but strange supreme's a very close
one strange support i think we'll be
seeing more of him we've seen him and
party thor together in the trailer so
you'll get to see strange supreme and
party thor hanging out together i think
that's going to happen
i think that would be cool um
and i think i think if we were going to
see
anybody in the live action i'm sure well
the watcher um i think he would be the
number one person
right he's the bridge but if i had to
bring number two i i would say strange
supreme um but hey rumors of haley
atwell showing up and and i really
really want to see her live action doing
the captain carter thing because i
actually i don't know what i really
enjoyed the first episode of what if
the story wasn't that different but i
liked watching the captain carter
animation and her throw the shield and
everything like that i would love it
more
if it was live action
after the last um what if episode we
should have at hand ready written out
our
one through nine favorite or eight or
whichever it is now episodes seven and
we'll bang them out
uh you're saying do that after
everything
well i'm going to try to have the list
done beforehand because i'm going to get
all confused if i try to do it live but
yeah we should do it after everything's
done
our favorite list
yeah the what ifs
yeah we can do one through eight
but we have two more episodes left oh
and after the last one yeah we'll we'll
do it yeah we have two more left and i
think
probably the next one's gonna be
assemble the multiverse the
the
it's either going to be like the
guardians of the multiverse or like the
avengers of the multiverse or something
like that the last one of you what if
the watcher
stops watching
give me the remote
yeah
that'll be fun too yeah i'm pumped for
the
episode yeah i see a lot of people
this is what i like a lot of people like
oh your second episode is about this
episode's the best like i'm glad you all
like those episodes
i'm glad that we all have different
episodes that we
like the most like i always encourage
like even when we do reviews and if i
like a movie or don't like a movie
i always encourage people to make their
own opinions and there are some people
that says a1 they want they want i've
always i've always said make your own
opinion don't don't just
you know base it off of ours uh but for
those who i saw some people talking
about like chongqi or something like
that i still i think that that movie is
freaking cold uh that's one of my top
five favorite
marvel movies now and uh
i mean it's got the highest rotten
tomatoes audience
rating ever out of like any marvel movie
so
clearly a lot of people share my same
offense um but if you didn't end up for
you
i i haven't decided if it's taken i
haven't decided if it's if it's four or
five which would be ragnarok
it fights with ragnarok so it's avengers
avengers infinity war avengers in game
and then ragnarok or shangji
the way i'm explaining it when i'm asked
because i haven't i have a hard time
comparing endgame to
you know
captain america
so i'm just talking like
the way when i'm asked it's my second
favorite origin movie of all time for
the for marvel what's your first
iron man iron man hand
no questions asked i don't think
anything will ever beat iron man for me
i've seen it 150 million times well
that's a different ranking like
ranking just the origins because that's
how i've been able to explain it because
how do you how do you compare end game
to any other movie right in the marvel i
always just i personally compare my
overall enjoyment of the movie
and right in that enjoyment comes
the qualms i have with the movie as well
right right you have to add all that i
really have to sit down and make a real
list i've never actually done it
but um
sean cheese without a doubt my second
favorite origin film the character is
going to be phenomenal phenomenal moving
forward and i can't wait to see what he
brings to the table yeah and i think
speaking of specifically sean chi i
actually thought it was a beautiful
movie like visually and story wise like
i just think i just think a lot of it
was done so well now
i did give it like a 9 out of 10 because
well
i'm not going to talk about it because i
i don't know i don't know i don't know
who's seen here all night well i don't
know who hasn't seen it yet and i don't
my qualm is i know a lot of people still
have it right my qualm is with the part
of the end
right i know i know exactly what you're
referring to right and it's not that big
of a deal
um but it's enough it's enough to be a
qualm i have qualms it's enough to be a
qualm um i have quad
and you know i stated that my review
that i did i just you know there's one
part um
but overall i love that movie uh like mr
anderson said right there seriously a
phenomenal movie um yeah it's a
masterpiece i think i think i would call
it a masterpiece
i feel like someone said that
but uh hey guys this was fun um black it
was i actually like kind of getting into
these conversations because this one one
of our best what if chats i think yeah
even though it wasn't entirely about
what if
but
to circle back i think the episode was
great i think actually the captain
marvel did play a really good part in
the episode i think it was perfect i i
don't
thi i don't think i have qualms in this
episode speaking of qualms i
for what it was i think it was awesome i
think everything had a really good
purpose i think all the different
characters showing up were really great
i think loki showing up and i'm talking
about them being brothers were great i
think
the fight between thor and captain
marvel was fantastic i think the
interaction with jane foster and thor
was fantastic that you know even though
it wasn't the same
uh they still got to get i still because
i like that i i like like this idea of
like fate you know what i mean they're
destined to be degraded right they're
destined together i i really
you know kind of like i agree they're
destined to not be the guy right it's
like i i like the
i like that i don't have any clubs with
this
nope
nope nope nope nope no clumps so
all right everybody that's it for today
um i'm gonna have some
interesting videos coming out tomorrow i
think um
sounds like it
well there's a lot of news that came out
tonight
and i haven't
i haven't decided what i'm doing yet
uh so it's super late for me right now
so i might
decide in the morning or i might decide
right now i'm not sure
but
good videos tomorrow
so i appreciate everybody showing up
tonight i appreciate uh everybody who
chatted and of course i always
appreciate all the super chats uh
appreciate mr anderson being a great mod
as always um and even if you're just
here watching not chat or anything like
that thanks for being here we super
appreciate it i hope you enjoyed it and
uh two episodes left and i think it's
about to get big i think it's about to
get uh
exciting because i think the
connectivity is about to make it
up
on another level
i agree yeah
so all right
i will see you guys next week
and then the week after that we're gonna
get a little bit of a break um but
oh we're gonna be we're both gonna be
out of town the next live stream
to log into louie's computer so i'll
figure it out we'll still have the live
streams we're just gonna be remote um
but yeah guys don't forget to subscribe
to chris
there we go hi i'm chris if you haven't
over at cosmic culture mr anderson just
dropped the links
uh for it in the chat
go be sure to subscribe up over here too
guys
uh be sure to subscribe to chris great
channel um he's also like a room away
from me right now so ah
any edits for cosmic winter so with me
yeah whenever there's a mess up usually
my fault
it's always chris although today i fixed
one of your your mistakes what did i
mess up in today you called the title
chilled not child
but i fixed it
you called it chilled
no you called the child shut up i didn't
do the title today you did
all
uh all right guys have a good night no
problem sarah i appreciate that i'm glad
everybody can come in here and chat we
can talk about this stuff so all right
love you guys all
catch you guys in a week